mi sono anche vestito da relatore per
partecipare oggi parlare di forma
è un argomento trattare il formaggio un
argomento estremamente difficile perché
sarebbe molto più facile se potessimo
far passare un piatto e potessimo
degustare il proprio il formaggio
naturalmente è una piccola provocazione
non parleremo di formaggio mi soffermerò
sono cinque secondi su questa immagine
questo è uno stomaco di capretto
all'interno c'è il latte coagulato
di conseguenza questo è la questa è la
prima fabbrica di formaggio così come
l'uomo l'ha conosciuta è uno spunto è
una è un'introduzione per poter
affrontare un argomento più ampio senza
alcuna pretesa di generalizzare troppo
un consumo sostenibile un consumo
consapevole da parte di tutti perché
utilizziamo il formaggio come paradigma
l'uomo preistorico conosceva il
formaggio senza aver studiato
l'oppressore che sapeva che il latte si
coagula va è diventata qualcosa di
solido ed è lì che scott si è scoperto
il formaggio non c'erano frigoriferi non
c'era tecnologia non c'era nulla
assolutamente ma le proteine e grassi
nobili poteri grassi e proteine nobili e
venivano conservate all'interno di
questa massa massa solida che è il
formaggio e che arriva fino ai giorni
nostri
oggi si parla molto di alimentazione
sana rispetto della natura paiono delle
parole e talvolta buttata al vento
spero non quello che dico io adesso in
realtà sono un'introduzione che il mondo
del formaggio e i casari tentano di
utilizzare per poter approfondire un
discorso davvero più vasto
oggi si s ci si sofferma se pensiamo un
attimino a un tipo di vita tipi di vite
tipo di ditte
diciamo intensive oggi tutti vorremmo
mangiare bene e vivere bene avere del
tempo per noi stessi in realtà credo che
la maggioranza delle persone presenti in
questa sarà avranno vite frenetiche
tempo perfino fare nulla si mangia molto
spesso in piedi
tante volte male molto spesso non si sa
quello che si mangia
quindi la qualità dove sta in tutto
questo molto spesso si dimentica la
frustrazione a volte deriva anche dal
fatto che gli obiettivi che noi abbiamo
quindi quelli di avere uno stile di vita
sano quelli di avere oggetti belli
quelli di avere al di là degli aspetti
personali naturalmente su cui non
naturalmente non sono assolutamente
qualificato per parlare di quelli non
sono qualificato parlare contrastano
qualche cosa
il prezzo di quello che noi acquistiamo
quindi io voglio mangiare bene però poi
alla fine
chiunque di noi dice ma quanto costa
dimentichiamo un aspetto fondamentale il
valore di quello che noi mangiamo e
questa cosa può essere declinata il
termine cosa non dovrebbe utilizzarlo
dovrebbe essere utilizzato in conferenze
però questo aspetto può essere
utilizzato per qualsiasi alimento e
aspetto della nostra vita
che cosa noi mangiamo qual è il valore
di quello che noi mangiamo il formaggio
grazie ad una storia millenaria e zoe un
po da questi ragionamenti da te
formaggio non è stata una invenzione ma
è stata la scoperta
nessuno si è messo a un tavolino e
nessuno ha detto oggi io produrrano del
formaggio non vorrei essere frainteso
perché naturalmente anche qui non è la
sede
non si tratta di decrescere
assolutamente anzi è l'esatto opposto
si tratta di riscoprire delle radici
perché se noi pensiamo che per fare un
ottimo formaggio è sufficiente perché
veramente sufficiente partire da una
materia prima atti ma a partire da una
materia prima eccezionale quindi da un
latte eccezionale che è poi un alimento
che si coagula anche solo naturalmente
il latte non ha bisogno di nulla per
potersi coagulare possiamo ben capire
che tutte adesso vedo passare delle
immagini loro vanno senza seguire il
filo del ragionamento l'industria
naturalmente ad ada de grandi impulsi ma
la base rimane sempre quella un ottimo
prodotto di partenza in questo nel
nostro settore nel settore caseario
ma questo io inviterei a fare uno sforzo
anche di fantasia può essere portato in
tutti i settori
bisogna immaginarsi animali che
pascolano liberi che mangiano su
appezzamenti di terra polifiti quindi
dove non c'è l'intervento dell'uomo
sembrano una immagine bucolica
a quel tempo è passato e finito per
quell animale li produrrà un
piccolissimo litro di latte un solo
letto del latte che potrà essere
utilizzato per far la decima parte di un
formaggio straordinario quella decima
parte di formaggio straordinario sulla
nostra tavola
avrà una resa eccezionale lo stesso può
valere per il vino lo stesso può valere
per qualsiasi cosa
un maglione un pantalone una scarpa il
formaggio non hanno nome non è cool
mangiare un formaggio buono ma noi
dobbiamo ragionare e l'invito che io
personalmente faccio è il settore che io
ho anche a cui un onore di appartenere
ho avuto faccio solo 30 secondi una
regressione spero di non annoiare
nessuno ho avuto una discussione
epistolare con il direttore di un
importante quotidiano perché parlando di
un avvenimento avvenuto quest'estate
un'uscita assolutamente scomposta di una
persona delle istituzioni ha detto basta
con questi toni da venditori di caciotte
io ho la fortuna anzi sì io non dirò che
naturalmente perché non si possono fare
nomi né nel bene né nel male
io mi sono permesso di scrivere in
questo la posta elettronica skype ci
aiuta moltissimo e lui ha avuto anche la
gentilezza di rispondermi io non perché
voglio insegnare niente a nessuno
lungi da me questa cosa per chi vuole
modo in tutto e adesso senza veramente
l'unica cosa che deve mescolare il latte
non esco non voglio mescolare troppo
agli argomenti ma si tenga ad avere
questa bulimia si mette tutto dentro il
calderone ok è una cosa volgare è un
venditore di caciotte no io voglio
affrontare questo argomento dicendo c'è
una grande nobiltà in quello che si fa
dipende sempre in come si fa questo
assolutamente io non l'orgoglio di poter
dire il mio impegno come piccolo
imprenditore come oggi il relatore qua è
quello di dire c'è grande qualità
dietro a un prodotto che può essere
formaggio può essere un vino lo capiremo
oggi si in particolare nel mondo del
vino si dice il vino buono si fa nella
vigna e
allora perché il formaggio buono non
deve farsi nel pascolo o nel caseificio
ma per quale motivo è l'alimento buono
non deve farsi senza sminuire tutti i
prodotti che lo compongono
possiamo farle no talvolta di
conservanti del glutammato di
insaporitori quando un prodotto naturale
non ha bisogno di alcuni insaporitore è
così e chiaro che c'è un aspetto
culturale e questo anche qui volendo
allargare un attimino gli orizzonti è un
aspetto culturale che può valere per
tutti i settori
se non si conosce quello che si ha di
fronte davvero potranno stare a parlare
ora intera il cecchino che marco ha
ingaggiato per abbattere dopo il
diciottesimo minuto adesso forse lavora
se non si conosce quello che si ha di
fronte e diventa davvero difficile dare
che cosa torniamo al discorso di prima
il valore io se potessi continuare a
parlare probabilmente veramente dire
delle cose anche magari noiose e scadere
nel tecnico che non interessa nessuno e
non interessa assolutamente neanche me
ad entrare negli argomenti tecnici da un
paio di informazioni di tipo storico
anche per contestualizzare quanta
importanza avesse la qualità e
soprattutto la qualità di questo
prodotto di cui parliamo
il kit tav al formaggio e nelle antiche
civiltà rurali era il casaro l'uomo che
aveva a che fare con il casus casaro se
noi pensiamo all'etimologia e kaiser e
il cesare il kaiser rockstar non è
megalomania questa si trattava di
persone che potevano permettere agli
abitanti delle varie le varie dei vari
centri abitati di avere l'energia
sufficiente per poter fare tutta la
creatività le attività di caccia di
pesca di raccolta era veramente un
propulsore di attività
oggi noi vorremmo tornare a ri
concentrarci su questo dando anche
segnalando e sottolineando un aspetto
non facciamoci mai nessuno di noi si
faccia mai convincere da un prezzo basso
un prezzo basso e nel nostro settore io
posso portare a diverse testimonianze un
prezzo basso e intrigante perché è uno
dice io ho voglia di mangiare anch'io ho
voglia di bere anch'io quel vino voglio
mangiare anch'io quel formaggio voglia
di mangiare anch'io quella carne c'è un
prezzo basso molto spesso il prezzo
basso nasconde un valore ancora più
basso di quello che presso vuole
descrivere il prezzo basso
è un ragionamento questo che io tengo
sempre cioè quelli tenere sempre a mente
quando quando svolgo il mio lavoro
un prezzo basso e in realtà se andiamo a
valutarlo rispetto al valore è molto
caro oggi facevamo poco fa ho anche un
esempio nessuno si sognerebbe di dire
sono venuto con un'automobile ed è anche
loro sono venuti con automobile è la mia
automobile un'automobile che costa 5
mila euro
probabile un automobile costa 200mila
euro io non potrei dire ti hanno fregato
questo è dovuto alla ignoranza la non
conoscenza di quello che ci sta dietro è
comunque un automobile ma come è stata
fatta con l'automobile lo stesso non lo
possiamo declinare su quello che a noi
più per noi è più importante cioè
l'alimentazione il cibo
concludo veramente dicendo facendo un
altro un esempio io mi esprimo ma anche
per esempio perché è davvero non è un
mondo difficile questo che io di cui
faccio parte perché possa essere
spiegato ripeto molto meglio sarebbe
fare un assaggio un assaggio ceco lo è
dire piace non piace mettersi così in
gioco il prezzo può venire dopo
che cosa c'è dietro che storia c'è ci
sono pascoli c'è un allevamento
estensivo animali che non sono stressati
e quindi pensiamo anche questo le
estensi vita animali non stressati
pascoli che si rigenerano contro gli
intensi vita l'azione dell'industria lo
stress dell'animale e l'allevatore che
come me come tutti noi imprenditori
quelli che sono i venditori deve fare un
conto economico e raggiro che punterà
all'intensità un latte fatto installa
rende tre volte tanto un latte fatto in
alpeggio
chiunque di noi gestisca anche solo un
portafoglio sa che se uno oggi mi farò
ma se dicesse davide attivati fare una
cosa che ti rende tre volte tanto direi
caspita si lava dobbiamo sempre pensare
che non alimentare mai un circuito
virtuoso come in questo caso invece una
agricoltura estensiva al contrario fa
quindi io ringrazio veramente tutti
perché l'attenzione e invito a pensare a
questa cosa
prezzi bassi intrigantissimo i prezzi
bassi ma le quantità quanta quantità ho
bisogno pagando poco per essere
soddisfatto e un'ultimissima cosa che
non vuole sembrare perdonatemi il
termine colloquiale e un abbuffata
non penso
a che cosa dovrà pagare in sanità un
domani quando dovrà veramente sopperire
a una cattiva alimentazione un occhio
tutti solo di riflettere su questa cosa
e vi ringrazio